yo what is up everybody it is prestige
er man luigi here with another Borland's
the pre-sequel legendary weapon guide
today I'm gonna be looking at the
torrent it which is a legendary and dot
all SMG it's red text is spray it to
slay it and overall it's just a fast
shooting SMG now what makes it a
legendary is that when you choose really
fast and especially when it's burst it
shoots a five shot burst in what seems
like one to two shots so it goes through
ammo fast but it kills people really
fast as well so it's a really high D I
say it's a really high dps which is
damage for a second if you don't know
except it does go through ammo
relatively as fast so when you gonna get
this from either I guess you can get it
multiple ways probably a vending machine
probably grind unit neither of those
ways are confirmed I to my knowledge and
the way I'm gonna show you hasn't been
confirmed by anyone else
I believe so this is the first comfort
confirmation video about where you can
get this gun I heard some other people
getting this gun from the mission where
you have to kill Meg which is a thresher
from dr. yaker Nakayama and I did it
myself and I was able to get the SMG so
I think it's a confirmed job from Meg I
don't think anyone else drops it and I
think it's it's this is gonna be hard to
get if you're gonna try to grind grind
make it for a vending machine it and
also my legendary guys will not be
including grinding and vendor in we're
just gonna look at me looking at raid
boss or just drops from bosses so
without further ado I'm gonna get into
the video into the quest and how to get
this as mg enjoy as I said before it's
gonna be a quest you pick up from dr.
Nakayama it is the third quest
I believe he gives you I don't know if
he gives you any more I think it's the
third and final quest you do for an in
Hyperion hub of heal heroism the other
two are just kind of odd jobs that he
does for Jack and this is one where you
have to kill a thresher called Meg in a
trash compactor which is definitely a
Star Wars reference since going to trash
compactor it does come back sometimes
and you gotta kill a thresher snake-like
thing definitely Star Wars reference so
just gonna run over and press the button
I must warn after you do this meg is not
killable so if you want to get the gun
every time you kill her you're gonna
have to save and quit this is also a
really good XP farm in my mind since you
can get five like three to six thousand
for every time you kill her if you kill
her around the level that I'm killing
her at which is like 40 the quest is 43
I would suggest doing this quest at 50
so you can get a level 50 torrent I
wanted to get the video for you guys so
I did it earlier in my playthrough since
we're gonna take me a little bit longer
to get to level 50 now you see I farmed
her a lot probably over 40 times yeah
I'd say probably over 40 times and
finally I got a flying torrent SMG I
wanted I did not know what the gun was
gonna look like before I technically
didn't even know if it was a confirmed
drop but luckily it was and I decided
that even if it wasn't a confirmed drop
I was getting tons of XP from doing that
so I'm like it's worth it so you see
this is some of the gameplay of the tour
net action
I have never I'm never using up a SMG in
my playthrough up till now which is 46
is a lot so I don't have any ammo
upgrades on my SMG ammo like moonstone
upgrades so my ammo is very of I have a
very very small pool of SMG ammo
especially for such a fast shooting SMG
and you see the burst fire just takes
down enemies like that even not doing
burst fire just hit firing it still
takes down enemies really fast and I
know those guys were under level on a
few levels but you can see here it holds
its own completely well and completely
deserving of the legendary title even
when you're facing enemies that at your
level or above so I think it is a really
good SMG it might take out a little bit
of farming however you get if you do it
before level 50 you get a ton of XP so
it's pretty good and if you do it at
level 50 you get an even better SMG I
would like to go back and do this but I
don't think I have any ability to other
than starting a new character because
you cannot kill Meg after you do this so
make sure you once you kill Meg if you
do not
if you don't get it saving quit and then
just go get the mission for go get the
mission again from dr. Mackey ominous
and so will be considered failed and you
can just restart so I hope you guys have
enjoyed this video I appreciate it if
you got all the way to the end
stay keep a look out for my channel for
more Borderlands the pre-sequel videos
and legendary weapon guides make sure
you check out my other legendary weapon
guides if you haven't and that's about
it thanks for watching